as far and beyond and today I will talk
about safer lower bound in the for the
succinct boolean matrix vector
multiplication problem so today in the
morning I'm sure they've already talked
about some matrix vector multiplication
problem and we have seen some lower
bound so again so let's recall what the
problem is
we are given a in cross and boolean
matrix there's zero one matrix and our
goal is to first pre-process em and
store it in a data structure such that
at later point of time if I am given a n
dimensional vector V 0 1 vector I should
efficiently compute the value M V and
here of I mean I am just considering
this product to be over boolean say
meeting so that means I just replace
addition by all and multiplication by n
of course already know but still let's
see that now I mean this is just say an
example so there is a matrix M and say V
and to calculate this I just compute
just end of each of this entry and then
take off
and so let's talk about a little bit
about what's the motivation behind
studying this problem so this is
actually a special case of online matrix
vector multiply matrix vector problem
also known an MB so where I am we are
given a matrix a again boolean matrix
and there is a stream of vector coming
one at once and our goal is to compute
mvi but we cannot see any vector that
comes later point of time
and it is conjectured that even there is
no randomized algorithm that takes truly
sub cubic time can solve this problem
and this is actually a known as OMB
conjecture and well-known in the
harnessing P domain and introduced by
hinging and others in Slovak - Negus
and what is known so far this is a
result by Larsen and Williams that show
that when we can be solving n cube over
2 square root log and so this is not a
truly sub cubic time so that means the
amortized time is n square over 2 to the
square root log n so this arises the
question so can you show a sail probe
lower bound because there is a data
structure problem we have lots of tool
in our hand there are lots of resident
cell probated structure so caning
somehow so this is an upper bound so can
you just give a matching lower bound so
this is the question but and okay so by
self-promoter I mean we have seen lots
of rezar today that we just charge for
the number of sail axis so computation
is completely free
but unfortunately the answer is no we
cannot true and this is also by Larson
and Williams in the same paper they show
a data structure
I mean same probe data structure that
has quite a time into the 7 over 4 I
mean up to some log factor 1 abductor ok
so that means so my conjecture is
falling a fall since L probe model but
still I mean we can try to show some
lower bound and also it remains the
question that what is the true
complexity of this problem so it study
further and we actually achieve a query
time order into the 3 over 2 but the
point is that our algorithm is
randomized but previous Larson and
Williams algorithm was deterministic and
what we show is that our data structure
will look like something will store the
input matrix in a read-only memory and
then we also have a extra order in to
the 3 over 2 bits so this is the
redundant bits that we store along with
this input and then whenever some query
comes we'll prove in this data structure
the whole thing anyway so this type of
data structure is called systematic
succinct where we actually store the
input and also some a small amount of
redundant bits
so before going into the lower bound so
I mean what we've proved so let's just
do some warm-up so actually it is easy
to see that any greater structure that
support this Umrah query so that master
say T must be I mean query time must be
greater than in I mean it is very simply
easy to see but let's see so just
consider the in elementary basis vector
where the just in a vector such as the
say phosphate is one and second and so
on say in this example so is the
dimension type so there are five
elementary basis vector and what is the
value of mi di so this is basically the
earth column of a and so this is system
so this will reveal the first column so
this square so as a result if I can
answer my MD query for all this query
vectors then actually I can get back the
whole input matrix M and so that's why
we can get some information theoretic
lower bound in this way that we just
choose M uniformly randomly and so the
Shannon entropy is N squared now we can
just import the content of all the
cell's axis during this process of
answering M of T is and how do I so do
we just happen the contents a fast I
mean there is arbitrary order so in that
fixed ordering whatever it addressed I
just write the content of the cell
what is the assumption on the stage what
a how many we done is it's a useful so
here we are not consider so this is just
how I mean warm-up so I am just
considering any any data structure
understand if I store them all the
queries that all dancers that's like
exponentially so what is done in terms
if you think thoughtful about your plant
and yeah okay so that's a difficult it
says that output size so we are we are
just considering this MV problem
[Music]
now but we still have to approve that
answer right so that is already our n
bit vector word size is bit yes okay
here for simplicity I'm just positing
odd sizes because what if you can get it
out of nowhere you just don't need root
to read it like I mean it doesn't mean
that you need to read and bits
I mean without these Huffman you cannot
even a bit yeah okay so this is the
story so basically encoding length is T
n so say in the host case square Dynasty
so for answering in vector sign it TN
coding length and 40 and should be in
spare and that's why we'll get T is
greater than n okay so now let's come to
our result so what we show so we study
this lower bound problem in the succinct
data structure model so basically we
have this restriction that we our input
matrix is written on our read-only sale
and then some extra redundant bits say
are in amount of fields and okay so we
slightly further generalize that okay so
this extra redundant beat so this I can
access any point of time so we will not
charge for that we'll only charge for
accessing any bits from this input
matrix
so clearly if I can show a lower bounty
in this generalized model then that was
still hold for systematic succinct case
and what is show is that if the length
of this bits so this is say greater than
Ain and up to say in square by four I
mean this is any constant so then R
times T have to be greater than n cube
so there is a trade-off between this
amount of redundant bit and the same
amount of cell proofs that we need so
and our second result is that if iron is
less than n so then we have to probe
almost all the entries of the input
matrix and this is just a corollary of
this first one so this is just using our
very simple padding argument so then it
falls
so now for the remaining part of the
talk so let's try to give a proof
overview of this
so for the proof I slightly simplify the
statement and I'll say that okay I will
not prove this trade off but instead I
will say show that if R is less than n
to the 3 over 2 then query has to be
greater than n to the 3 over 2 and just
believe me that the same proof will work
just we have to save some parameter
angle so here is the proof idea so first
we will define our hard distribution on
the input matrices and then I will
select a special type of revealing
queries so that this query can reveal
actually lots of information from this
input matrix and then again just like in
warm-up example so we just encode the
bits that probe during these queries
now let's try to define this hard
distribution so here is what we will do
so we first divide this matrix so each
row will divide it into blocks and each
block is of length 2 square root n so
how many blocks are there so there will
be root n over 2 many blocks and now
I'll choose uniformly randomly I will
choose exactly one entry form each of
this block and set it to one and I just
set all the remaining entries to zero so
basically in our matrix so
in the each loop so there will be at
most routine over too many ones and
it'll show that I mean this entropy of
this distribution this is into the 3
over 2 over 2 log 2 square routine
because there are that many blocks and
for each block I have to specify this
position of this
now similarly let's try to construct the
revealing queries so I will design two
square root n mini query vectors and in
the following way so in the vector also
we'll just divided into blocks just as
in case of this matrix and these are
also of size two square rooting and now
in the Ridgid query vector what I will
do from each of this block I will just
look into the J position in each of this
block and I will just put one and
remaining I will just keep 0
so now let's see that how this Hansard
look like say suppose given I mean I
just choose my query vector for my this
leveling query set and now say the
answer vector so this I throw increase
one so how many such query vector can be
anybody say
earlier you are not alone don't laugh
since they are actually in each loop in
this matrix there are square root n over
2 many once so Atmos this many weary
vectors can make this entry 1 and for
the remaining it has to be 0 so there
are at most where root n over 2 many
factors for which this guy can be 1 a
now see so if suppose this guy is 0 so
then actually I learn a lot about it
about this matrix entries and what we
learnt so basically we learned that if
say V Jett on visit query so this is 0
so then that means in all this J th
position in this guy I mean in this
matrix they all are zeros
and since I know that for to square root
n minus square root n over to many
factors I have this zero so that means
for each block I know that many
positions are zero so if I can answer
all this queries then actually I learn a
lot about from each of this block and
how much I learn so basically given this
set of answers so actually now entropy
drops to log of square root n over two
because these are the positions that are
still undetermined so my one can be in
any of these positions
so now just try to use the encoding
argument so given this answer so how
much information it revealed
so basically previous entropy was this
guy this guy so the difference is into
the three over two and how many queries
I answered I answered to square root n
many queries and say the worst case B
probe was T so to answer all the queries
the total number of bits per will be at
most two square root n times T and now
just just like as in warm-up just happen
them and encoded in that way just tap in
all the contents so what we get okay so
and another thing is also that you can
also encode this R because using odd and
all this proof from the input matrix I
can get back all these answers so my
encoding length is R plus 2 T square
root N and since I know that R is less
than n to the 3 over 2 by 4 so what we
get so we still get T's
still in a bad shape okay what we will
do so here is the fix
we'll use a clever encoding will not
just a pin to all the contents instead
what we do so this is the clever
encoding so don't encode all the propped
entries but instead just input all the
one entries just because if suppose from
the encoding I can get all the one
entries I know that whatever remaining
probes that must be 0 so just encoding 1
entries of suffice and we just input
this 1 entries of all this query vectors
say so I say this is a key so these are
the set of all 1 entries and just input
as a subset of all the provinces so
there are 2 T Square Root and many probe
entries and now just encode this subset
so for that I need log of 20 square root
n to scape okay so if my so while
simulating if I answer all of them are
yeah since my query vectors are fixed I
know that these are the only query
vectors possible
okay so this is my encoding link now and
this is greater than this guy so just
one thing just recall that when we use
that given this answer so then we do not
have this extra K vector this now comes
because now we actually learn those 1
entries because I import those k1
entries so that means i know that i
explicitly know what where this k1
entries are in the input matrix so these
are the extra loss that we have but now
if you just message this thing so then
actually believe me that you will get it
just get at the end of 3 I mean these
are just calculation nothing else
so you're including better the query or
the sorry are you cutting better as a
query or the output
aye-aye sir you want to work so the
entries of the matrix will are not
balanced this is first page yeah this
has four surfaces
okay so you guys still have some primary
that is the case so then let's talk
about the upper bound also so how do we
get this upper bound just recall that we
achieve this amount of redundant bit is
order into the 302 and the query time is
also 301 and this matches this lower
bound okay so what the pre-processing
phase what we do we just enumerate over
so given this metric same we anew my to
her all the sub matrices and we just
find all the large sub matrices with
sparse row what do I mean by that
so by large sub matrices I mean that um
sub matrix that covered the uncovered
matrix so a no into the three over two
entries of the uncovered metric and by
each row making sparse means in each row
I have this one entry densities who are
less than 1 over square root in and now
I just leaves down all such sub matrices
and also I encode all this one entries
so how many sub matrices I have so I
have some addresses atmos square root n
mini sub matrix because of this
restriction that I just told large sub
matrices and for storing each of the sub
matrix I just need to invade most and
also to encode all the one entries I
know that each of my a matrix that we
actually store for them for each row
this is parts is parts in the sense of
one dense it is very small so that means
to just encode all this one entries I
just need a cross into the three over
and this is just my prepossessing step
and this is what I store as a data
structure this redundant bit and now
while doing they're answering the query
what I will do
so just given a query vector so from
this matrix I just first first of all I
discard all this columns so where the
corresponding entry is 0 and now I just
consider all the sub matrices that are
encoded in this redundant bits and now
for each of this one entries in this
query vector I just see that whether
there is also a corresponding one entry
in my encoding because remember they
recall that in the encoding I just
encode all the one entries also in those
sub matrices say here so I find one so
there is zero say here one I find one so
for each such I just said the
corresponding in the answer vector I set
it to one I keep on doing that and when
I am done so there is no such one entry
slept in my encoding so what I will do
for the remaining rows from this
uncovered part of the sub matrix
I just sample square root in many
positions and for those sample positions
I just check if there is a one if there
is a one I just said the corresponding
bit to one
and the thing is that since I know that
in my encoded part so I actually store
all the sub matrix that has one density
small so I know that either
here this uncovered part the one entropy
one density must be high and in that
case with high priority I will find this
one and otherwise the uncovered part so
this size is very small and in that case
actually I just read thou all the
remaining portion of the matrix and then
just decide on the answer
and so come to the open problem so as
you see so we just could show the lower
bound for the systematic succinct case
but it is still open that for non
systematic what kept me show it is not
clear from our argument that whether we
can at all generalize to non systematic
case and also another question that
actually our could've talked about in
the morning so this is the UM a problem
so where Larson and Williams show that
those entries into three over two and
redundant beat is n to the 3 over 2 but
we don't know any such matching lower
bound what actually we can so just with
a some small idea along with this
warm-up thing so we can actually show
that T is greater than n over log n we
don't know that whether this is the
right bound or not
[Applause]
Christiane's so right we have this
accent in your encoding you're sending
one of these I started yeah but that's
not I mean you because you're giving
those clothes for free yeah but what if
you just send the locations and just the
contents of those things that you proved
can you extend like to maybe I know at
least our resort own extreme to give a
better result in that case
so it seems like you learned a lot of
information every time you got it
geometry if if instead of doing this
problem over the bully which receives
you to do or some even a small finite
field yeah so okay so actually I just
choose to remain silent on that in our
paper actually we also consider this um
a problem over f2 and they are actually
we also show the similar lower bound for
the ume problem so this is much harder
than MV so they are also we show that
our T is greater than ank you
just to think it sucker again
[Applause]